there are certain things that men do the
woman just hate and that's what we're
talking about in this video I'm Daniel
and you're watching d LM model lifestyle
and we made a list of ten things that
men do the woman hate so let's start
with number one number one woman hated
if guys talk too much about themselves
you've met those guys they just go on
and on and on about themselves it just
basically tells a woman that he is
selfish self-absorbed and he's got an
ego that nobody likes number two is when
a guy smells bad I mean I get it we all
have different smells right but if a guy
cannot take ten minutes just to take a
shower and put some deodorant on no just
no and if you're one of those guys that
say I'm too lazy to shower just stop and
think about what you're saying
number three is catcalling woman hated
when a man drives past a woman
and he yells or he whistles you know it
just it makes them feel this respect
number one and number two it makes them
feel cheap
number four when a man acts differently
in front of his friends if a man act
weird or different in front of his
friends it immediately tells a woman two
things he cares more about his friends
than her and number two he cannot be
trusted number five
woman hates it when a man does not all
listen to her are you
especially when a guy looks on his phone
or the other direction when she's busy
talking if she's talking look her in the
eyes and show her that you really care
about what she thinks and feels number
six is when men have long dirty nails do
disgusting this and then those men are
shocked when a woman don't want them to
come near them seven is lying man woman
hates a guy that lies no relationship
can be built upon lies and it just takes
one lie to destroy a person's integrity
number eight these guys who never laugh
I know there's different personalities
out there and some people are more
serious right so it's okay to be a
serious guy but if you never ever laugh
of a woman she will think you hate life
or worse you hate her
number nine is not asking her questions
about her life now I don't mean to throw
a lot of questions at a woman and like
she feels interrogated no but a woman
will feel like you don't really care if
you don't ask her about her life number
ten is when men don't care about the way
they look it's okay if men are not
really interested in fashion and just
want to be the way that they are but if
men have an attitude of I couldn't care
less about being presentable especially
with women it's not a good idea all
right if you liked the video give me a
thumbs up subscribe and then not sit
cheers guys